expulsé l'ambassadeur français vas-y
côté les produits français
des dizaines de milliers de pakistanais
laissent éclater leur colère dans
plusieurs villes du pays
au delà des mots certains manifestants
piétinent le drapeau tricolore et l'
incendie
[Musique]
nous manifestons contre les français
contre les propos du président français
emmanuel macron pour qui les
commentaires on te contre le prophète
mahomet s'inscrivent dans la liberté
d'expression
si vous considérez cela comme la liberté
d'expression alors préparez-vous nous
inciterons le gouvernement pakistanais à
rompre toute relation avec la france et
à interdire tous les produits français
nous protestons contre l' annonce du
magazine français charlie hebdo de
republier ces caricatures sarcastique
ce même journal qui les avait déjà
publié en déclenchant la colère des
musulmans du monde entier qui s'étaient
rassemblés pour protester
ces rassemblements monstres contre les
caricatures de mahomet publiées par
charlie hebdo ont comme un air de déjà
vu
le blasphème est une question très
sensible au pakistan dans ce deuxième
pays musulman le plus peuplé au monde
même des allégations de france à l'islam
peuvent entraîner assassinat il un chat
on se souvient notamment de
l'acquittement en octobre 2018 de la
chrétienne asia bibi
elle avait passé près de neuf ans dans
les couloirs de la mort pour blasphème
ce qu'elle a toujours niées sa
libération avait provoqué démarche
violente dans tout le pakistan sous la
houlette des islamistes du tlpe est un
parti politique extrémiste